ROLL. MITCHELL HERE NIELSEN.
BELL CABALLERO DAWALY FURTADO
JONES LEYVA. MCGUIRE MONNING
MORLOCK PAN. SKINNER STERN
STONE NUMBER URUGUAY KASKI WE
HAVE A- THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THE SECRETARY NOTICES THE
PRESENCE OF A QUORUM GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE WE'VE JUST GOT
ONE ITEM BEFORE US TODAY WHICH
IS A CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
TO CHANGE HOW WE BUDGET FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
MISTER OBERNOLTE IS HERE TO
PRESENT THAT BIPARTISAN MEHSUD
MEASURE AC ELEVEN. WE WILL THEN
ALLOW TIME FOR QUESTIONS AND
PUBLIC COMMENT BUT BEFORE MR
OBERNOLTE BEGINS IF YOU DON'T
MIND SIR I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY
REFLECTED SOME OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT I WAS A PART
OF THAT LED TO THIS MEASURE
LAST YEAR YOU ALL WILL RECALL
THAT THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE CONDUCTED AN
EXTENSIVE EXECUTIVE SEARCH FOR
THE NEW ALBUM ALLEN. THIS WAS A
BI PARTISAN A BY CAMEL PROCESS
THAT RESULTED IN THE HIRING OF
MR PADDICK THE NEW ALLEN WHO'S
HERE WITH US TODAY. IN ADDITION
THE SEARCH PROCESS ALLOWED FOR
DIALOGUE ABOUT OUR EXPECTATIONS
OF THE LA AND THEIR GROWING
WORKLOADS AS WELL AS THE NEED
TO REINVEST IN THE OFFICE. THE
CAP ON THE LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET
HAS ARTIFICIALLY PREVENTED THE
NONPARTISAN LA L. STAFF FROM
KEEPING PACE WITH THE GROWTH OF
THE STATE BUDGET AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OF FISCAL
STAFF. THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE FOLLOW UP ON
THESE DISCUSSIONS BY HOLDING A
HEARING REGARDING THE LA L.
EARLIER THIS YEAR. I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH MR OLD BANALITY AND
APPRECIATE YOU ALLOWING ME TO
SIGN ONAS A CO AUTHOR OF THE
MEASURE. THAT IT'S TIME TO GIVE
THE VOTERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ALLOW FOR REINVESTMENT IN THE
AUDIO. I APPRECIATE HIS OFFICE
SHIP OF THIS MEASURE AND THEM
AGAIN PROP CO AUTHOR WITH THAT.
CITY TO NIELSEN IS IT HERE I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED.
WITH MR OBERNOLTE PRESENTING A
C. ELEVEN GOOD MORNING SIR
MORNING THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. BY THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE HAS BEEN AN
INTEGRAL PART OF STATE
GOVERNMENT FOR ALMOST EIGHTY
YEARS NOW OTHER ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN FORTY ONE. TO PROVIDE
NONPARTISAN UNBIASED FINANCIAL
ADVICE TO THE LEGISLATURE
THEY'RE MEANT TO BE THE COUNTER
WEIGHT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND THEY HAVE
PERFORMED ADMIRABLY IN THAT
ROLE THEY'VE BEEN A VERY
VALUABLE ADDITION. IN NINETEEN
NINETY PROP ONE FORTY WAS
PASSED BY THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS VERY
SPECIAL INTERESTS TO TERM
LIMITS. STRICT LIMITS ON
EXPENDITURES BY THE LEGISLATURE
BUT ONE OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF PROP ONE FORTY.
IS THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE BUDGET WAS CUT
BECAUSE TECHNICALLY THERE
UNDERNEATH THE SAME BUDGET ITEM
AS THE LEGISLATURE AS A
DEPARTMENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S. NINE NINETY.
YOUR PROP ON. THE LA OWES STAFF
WAS PRODUCED BY 60% THINK ABOUT
THAT OVER HALF. PRIOR TO NINE
NINETY. BUT WAIT NOT JUST A BUT
IT WAS DONE IN THE BILL.
CREATION AND THEY WOULD GIVE A
PRICE OF THOSE BILLS SINCE THEN
THEY'VE BEEN THEY HAD TO LIMIT
THE SCOPE OF THEIR ACTIVITIES
TO ONLY. BETTING ADVICE ON
BUDGET ITEMS ON THE VERY
LARGEST APPROPRIATIONS AND
BILLS. SO I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S A GOOD THING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW THE LA
HAS ROUGHLY THE SAME NUMBER OF
ANALYSTS AS THEY DID IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES AND TO GIVE
YOU SOME CONTEXT. THE STATE
BUDGET HAS GROWN BY OVER 5000%
SINCE THEN IN OTHER WORDS AND
OVER FIFTY TIMES AND THEY'RE
DOING THAT ANALYSIS WITH THE
SAME NUMBER. OF ANALYSTS SO NO
I'M A SMALL GOVERNMENT GUY WANT
TO KEEP THE SIZE OF GOVERNMENT
AS SMALL AS POSSIBLE BUT I MAKE
AN EXCEPTION WHEN IT COMES TO.
THE AGENCY THAT WERE TRUSTING
HELP US MAKE GOOD DECISIONS
WHEN I COME TO FISCAL
EXPENDITURES. BY THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT ECA
ELEVEN WOULD PROTECT AND BACK
BEFORE THE VOTE. WHETHER OR NOT
THE LA SHOULD BE WITHIN THE
SAME BUDGET. LINE UP I'M AS
THE- TEACHER WHETHER NOT THEY
SHOULD HAVE. THEIR SAY. THEIR
OWN. I STRUCK BELIEVE IT
SHOULDN'T MATTER I THINK THE
WILL OF WITH US I WOULD REQUEST
RIVAL NACA ELEVEN HAPPY HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE. QUESTION ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR THE
BILL. A GOOD WE HAVE A MOTION A
MISTER THIS ONE OFTEN DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENT ON BEHALF OF
THE ADMINISTRATION. YES. VEGAS
WOULD OFTEN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE'LL MAKE A COUPLE OF
BRIEF COMMENTS AND THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER
MOORE OBERNOLTE. TO THE PART OF
FINANCE WORKS VERY CLOSELY WITH
LA OUT THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR. ON THIS PROPOSED
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS AND
SEND THE MINISTRATION HAVE NOT
TAKEN A POSITION. HOWEVER
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE VOTES WE
DO WANT TO NOTE THREE KEY
ISSUES. FIRST WE NOTE THAT IF
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE IF THIS AMENDMENT WERE
TO PASS A IT'S UNCLEAR WHERE
EXACTLY IT WOULD BE FUNDED BY
THERE WOULD STILL BE FUNDED.
WITHIN THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
OR WHETHER IT WOULD BE A
SEPARATE GENERAL FUND ITEM AND
IF IT WERE A SEPARATE GENERAL
FUND ITEM OR IF THERE WERE A
MARGINAL INCREASE. IN THE LA
BUDGET BEYOND WHAT'S IN THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET RIGHT NOW
THAT FUNDING WOULD NO LONGER BE
AVAILABLE FOR OTHER GENERAL
FUND PURPOSES. THE SECOND POINT
I WANT TO MAKE IT IF THE COMES
A SEPARATE GENERAL FUND ITEM.
DâN EIGHT LEVEL FUNDING THERE
WOULD BE CONTINGENT ON THE
OVERALL BUDGET PROCESS. AND AS
A RESULT IN A POSSIBLE FUTURE
YEAR FUTURE ADMINISTRATION.
FUNDING FOR THE L. L. MAY NOT
BE GUARANTEED UNDER THAT
SCENARIO. AND FINANCE NOTES
THAT DURING THE NINETEEN
NINETIES AT THE GOVERNOR AT THE
TIME IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES.
VETOED FUNDING FOR THE
COMMISSION ON STATE FINANCE
WHICH PERFORMED REVENUE AND
EXPENDITURE FORECASTING AND
THAT FIND A FUNDING WAS NOT
SUBSEQUENTLY. RESTORED AND
FINALLY FINANCE ONE OF THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT. DOES NOT
CHANGE THE CAP ON TOTAL
AGGREGATE EXPENDITURES OF THE
LEGISLATURE. RATHER IT STATES
THAT LA EXPENDITURES SHALL NOT
BE INCLUDED IN CALCULATING
THOSE EXPENDITURES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. AND SO THIS IS
JUST TO SAY THAT IN THE FUTURE
SUBJECT TO THE CELL.
APPROPRIATIONS WOMEN IN THE
TOTAL AT AVERAGE EXPENDITURE
LIMITS BUT THAT WOULD STILL BE
SUBJECT TO LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
TO NEGOTIATIONS. BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. THANK YOU ARE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND
PROVIDE ANY COMMENTS OR ANY
RESPONSE THE MINISTRATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTARY I
THOUGHT I'M IN AGREEMENT WITH
EVERYTHING THAT WAS SAID I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THAT
TO BE A BUDGETARY DISCUSSION.
WE HAVE HAD HISTORICALLY OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF DECADES VERY
PRODUCTIVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION. I THINK
THE POINT THAT YOU'RE MAKING IS
IN THE FUTURE IF MAYBE THE
RELATIONSHIP WAS NOT SO
HARMONIOUS THAT THIS MIGHT BE A
CONTENTIOUS ISSUE. AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD DEAL WITH WHEN THE TIME
COMES BUT FOR THE MEAN TIME I
DON'T THINK IT'S HEALTHY. FOR
US TO BE IN A SITUATION WHERE
WE GOT 60% FEWER ANALYSTS THAN
WE DID. BEFORE NINETEEN NINETY
IN A BUDGET THAT CONTINUES TO
GROW IN COMPLEXITY STATE
GOVERNMENT THE CONTINUES TO
GROSS. THIS IS A GOOD FOR ONLY
CAL ABOUT OUR LEGISLATIVE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST RIGHT.
THAT NUMBER JUST. QUICK THINGS
BEFORE I GO TO DOCTOR PAN AND
SENATOR ROBB. THE FALL I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU TO THE OPENING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT YOU KNOW
THERE'S ADDITIONAL WORK THAT WE
HAVE PUT ON THE BACKS FRANKLY
THEY'LL ANNOUNCE THEIR-
ANALYSIS OF ALL THE BALLOT. IT
IS RENDON THAT'S IN. THE NUMBER
OF. KIDS THAT ARE ON. ALAN
GROSS THAT. WHATEVER FUTURE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD BE WILLING
TO UNDERSTAND ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE LA L. TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND NOT PUSH BACK ON FUNDING
FOR LA EITHER WITH THAT SENATOR
PAN. THANK YOU AND OF THE
SENATE OBERNOLTE THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD CERTAINLY
AND SUPPORT I JUST. WANTED
CLEAR FIGHTS AS A THIRD
FINANCES TESTIMONY AND MAYBE
JUST A MISPERCEPTION MY PART
BUT- BASICALLY ANY CURRENTLY
THE LA ANY DALY AS WITHIN THE
CAP RIGHT NOW. WE STILL HAVE TO
BUDGET FOR HOW MUCH THE LA ACT
I MEAN IT'S NOT LIKE THEY HAVE
A GUARANTEED AMOUNT OF MONEY.
IS THAT YES SAID THAT THAT IT
THAT IS CORRECT THE ONE
DIFFERENCE IS THAT RIGHT NOW IN
THE BUDGET ACT THAT'S ENACTED.
DE APPROPRIATIONS FOR THE LA IS
A TRANSFER FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET SO THEN THE OVERALL IT
IT'LL SHOW WAS ZERO IN THE
BUDGET ACT AND DAN IT'S
BASICALLY FROM THE OVERALL
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET MONEY GOES
FROM THERE. TO THE LA OUT RIGHT
BUT IN IN BUT I MEAN IT IS PART
OF THE BUDGET SO IT'S- SO IS A
UNILATERAL DECISION BY THE
LEGISLATURE HOW MUCH. GETS OUT
OF OUR ALLOCATION OR AS PART OF
THE BUDGET AGREEMENT THAT THE
GOVERNOR ALSO SIGNED SAID THIS
IS HOW MUCH WENT TO THE L. L.
SO IT IS IN THE OVERALL BUDGET
AGREEMENT BUT IT IS PART OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET RIGHT AND IN
FACT ACTUALLY AS SOON OBERNOLTE
JUST TO CLARIFY. THERE'S IS
THERE ANY PROVISION IN THIS
PARTICULAR A CPA THAT PREVENTS
THE LEGISLATURE IF WE WISH TO
ACTUALLY DESIGNATE PART OF
ALLOCATION TO THE LA IF FOR
SOME REASON NOW DURING A
DOWNTURN THAT WAS GONNA BE PART
OF THE BUDGET SOLUTION TO FULLY
FUND THE ALE CERTAIN. ABOUT
THAT JUST THIS IS VERY SIMPLE
IT SIMPLY REMOVES THE LA FROM
THAT CAPITA IS NOT SAY WHERE
THE FUNDING FOR THE LA COMES
FROM RIGHT SO THEREFORE IT'S
BASICALLY BE DISCUSSION BETWEEN
THE LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR OF
COURSE THE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATORS AND THE GOVERNOR
WILL SIDES SIGNED SO. I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT ISSUE JUST
TO. THAT I MEAN I DON'T THINK
THERE'S I DON'T SEE THIS AS
BEING A CREATING AN- INCREASE
OF OWN ABILITY TO THE L. L. IN
TERMS OF THE FUNDING. THANK YOU.
SENATOR ROBB THING THEN I'M
FEATURES DELIGHTED TO EVEN
THOUGH I DON'T RECOGNIZE YOU
ANYMORE. I JUST WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT I'M DELIGHTED TO
SUPPORT THIS I CERTAINLY HOPE.
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION. RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE WORK IS
PERFORMED BY THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE BUT NOT ONLY
TO US. BUT ALSO TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN TERMS
OF FLUSHING OUT AND MAKING RICH%
THE CONVERSATION IN THE
DIALOGUE OVER THE- SOMETIMES
VERY HEAVY BUDGET ISSUES. THERE
WE HAVE TO GRAPPLE WITH HERE.
JUST AS WE RECOGNIZE THAT IN
TIMES OF A BUDGET CRUNCH WHEN
THINGS ARE TOUGH IN CALIFORNIA.
WE MAY HAVE TO MAKE IT JUST WE
WILL MAKE ADJUSTMENTS OBVIOUSLY
TO OUR BUDGET. AND WE MAY HAVE
TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
OFFICE OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
BUDGET AT THE SAME TIME AS WE
TAKE A LOOK AT THE LA SO IT'S
JUST IT'S NOT A ONE SIDED THING
HERE. IN TIMES OF DIFFICULTY WE
ALL MAY HAVE TO TAKE A HER CUT
HOPEFULLY NOT SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS THANK YOU SIR
FOR BRINGING IT. IF YOU OF ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THREE NINE ARE WE ARE PUBLIC
COMMENT. SEE NO PUBLIC COMMENT
WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ACA ELEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO BE ADOPTED AND RE REFER
TO COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
MITCHELL HI I NIELSEN NIELSEN
I'D BILL. WELL I CAN BE ERA
COMPARE I DOLLY HER DAUGHTER
JONES JONES I LEYVA. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE MINING. MONEY NINE MORE
LUCK MORE LIKE I CAN. HI RON
ROTH AYE SKINNER AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN STONE STONE I NUMBER.
NINE NUMBER GUY WAY BECAUSE HE-
BECAUSE THE HI. AS THE
SECRETARY OF CALCULATING MISTER
OBERNOLTE LET ME JUST SAY TO
YOU THAT WHERE I COME FROM THE
ONLY APPROPRIATE RESPONSE TO
SENATOR RAFI IS. DON'T HATE THE
PLAYER HATE THE GAME. YOU KNOW.
THE JURY IS STILL OUT NO NO NO
YOU'RE THE JURY OF PEERS
RATIFIED WE LIKE TO LOOK. YEAH.
I THINK THE. WE'RE GONNA HOLD
THE ITEM OPEN GOAL WE CAN HOLD
ITEM OPEN JUST MOM BECAUSE OF
THAT ONE MORE MEMBER THAT'S ON
THEIR WAY DOWN THAT THEY WANT
TO ADD ON THE CURRENT VOTE.
SYSTEMS TO MORE LIKE LIKES TO
NOTICE FOURTEEN ZERO BUT WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THE ITEM OPEN. AFTER.
SHE DID WAS GONNA TRY. ONE MORE.
TIME SHE DID NOT. COULD YOU
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE.
DOLLY TACO. HI HER TITLE II
MCGUIRE STERN. YESTERDAY I
WANNA HOLD ITEM OPEN THANK YOU.
YEAH
. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE STERN.
YEAH. SO YOU WOULD HAVE NO
VISIBLE. IT'S NOT. THIS IS LIKE
.
THIS CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
DOLLY I'D DIE I STERN. AND I.
THAT'S THAT'S CALLED TIMING.
YET AGAIN IT'S MAKING SURE THE
VOTE IS EIGHTEEN TWO ZERO THE
MEASURE. ACCESS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COMMITTEE STANDS ADJOURNED